boy we played that of kamala harris was
really the people
interviewing her that were fascinating
what shills they are
but what do we make of this as a
physiological and psychological matter
why the cackling
jesse waters is one of america's noted
experts on cackling he's the author of
how i saved the world and we're happy to
have mine tonight jesse good to see you
what do you make of this
well as someone who made his career
doing man on the street interviews
tucker i feel like i'm uniquely
qualified to recognize
when someone's uncomfortable in public
and you're right this is
a sign of discomfort when she's
presented with a topic or a question
where she's unsure or uncomfortable she
resorts to cackling
in our industry we refer to this as a
defense mechanism
layman's terms perhaps would be a glitch
in the system a tick
or a tell in poker and she does it for
several reasons
one to soothe her anxiety two to buy her
time
if she's unsure she can use that time to
formulate a response
three to kind of guide the vibe of the
interview from a
serious to a less serious one and then
finally
it's kind of a lame attempt to form a
bond with the person asking her
a tough question and you saw this fail
miserably
with lester holt who just sat there
stone-faced
as she laughed in his face about real
issues with the border and i have
been studying when she does this she
tackles when she's asked a question
about her relationship
with president obama she tackles when
she's asked about her ideology
she's cackled also when she's asked
about her management ability i.e the
border and she also
laughs uncontrollably in an audience
setting where she's not on prompter
and she's failing to connect with that
audience so those are the results of my
behavioral psychological analysis and
thank you for giving me this opportunity
because i feel like this is one of my
rare talents
i think i think your analysis is spot on
perfect
so just to bottom line it if you were
playing poker with her
and she started cackling you'd double
down
she's bluffing you picked it up that's
exactly right
jessie waters thank you it's interesting
one last thing it's interesting you
pointed out she
cackles when asked about a relationship
with joe biden so she was asked by
by stephen colbert about that big moment
in the debate where she accused him of
being a racist
she just laughs and that's interesting
something to follow
imagine how much he dislikes him jesse
waters the great jessie waters thank you
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else